[Music]
what it certainly been slow in heaven
no one could dispute that in my view
it's been it's been far too slow look we
can go back over the referendum campaign
in detail if you like it was said many
times during that referendum campaign by
people on the leave side and by people
on the remains
remain lost Michael so no matter how
they do they do for the point that I'm
about to make because people on both
sides of the debate said very clearly
that leaving the European Union meant
leaving the customs union and leaving
the single market on both sides that was
made clear it what it was made you you
can save rubbish but the facts are there
with surveillance a Q&A very soon carry
on they did saved and so it's it's not
it's not a matter it's not a matter of
ideology it's a matter whether you like
it or not and I'm sure there are many of
you here this afternoon who don't like
it but it is a matter of implementing
the votes of seventeen point four
million people and what about a
transition line that's the pragmatic
polar because that was also on the vote
leaves slogan that there was a statement
that there would be a transition and it
will be smooth that that depends on the
outcome of our negotiations with the
European Union the European Union what
you can't you know it depends
negotiation is a two-way process and the
European Union has my view being very
obdurate in its attitude and we have
well I thought you know you may disagree
but I think it has and I don't think
that our negotiators have covered
themselves with glory III I don't I
don't think we have taken the right
approach to those that negotiations and
I think they couldn't should have been
done differently and then we might have
had a different outcome so I still hope
there'll be an agreement and all the
leadership candidates in the current
contest without exception as far as I'm
aware have said they would prefer an
agreement and they would work towards an
agreement
but some of them have said that if
there's no agreement we would have to
leave with that one that may be the only
way in which we can implement the the
the desire of seventeen point four
million people and if we are talking
about populism and not brexit which is
what this debate is supposed to be about
you cannot possibly say that it is in
any way wrong to respect the views of
seventeen point four million people and
to try and give effect to them for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you